normally Donald Trump makes a huge show
of everything he signs new legislation
executive orders presidential memos
happy Pesach cards to his Jewish friends
whatever right not so for that recently
passed Russian sanctions bill there were
questions what would Trump do about this
bill is he going to veto it well the
optics would be terrible
will he does not sign it and eventually
it will become the law so he can't be
criticized for signing it but he can't
be criticized for obstructing it well
ultimately he signed it very quietly no
press no cameras but he also called it
unconstitutional the White House
announced the signing of this Russian
sanctions bill
shortly after 11:00 a.m. at 11 a.m.
Eastern yesterday and they said the bill
includes quote a number of clearly
unconstitutional provisions wait a
second the guy who was the Constitution
candidate willingly signed something
into law that is not constitutional I
thought the oath of office that Trump
signed off on agreed to pledge to uphold
when he was inaugurated was to protect
and defend the Constitution of the
United States and he willingly signed
something that's not constitutional well
I mean what was he supposed to do the
bill is going to become law one of three
ways whether he signs it whether he
vetoes it and it's overridden or whether
he just ignores it and it becomes law so
at this way this way I mean he can go
down kicking and screaming but at least
he doesn't have to face the backlash of
looking like he's so clearly tied to
Russia well that's the argument that
some were making which is listen Trump
doesn't have to agree with it he's doing
the right thing by not obstructing this
is Trump not doing what the bad
Democrats did for so long of obstruction
by just going along with it you're
telling me that as a constitutional
conservative you support Trump opting
not to obstruct by signing something
into law that he believes is not
constitutional I think it is the most BS
defense of what Donald Trump did here
and John McCain doesn't even agree with
Trump and we talked earlier John McCain
now has a higher approval rating with
Democrats than with Republicans which is
we are living in bizarro world right now
john mccain said the framers of our
constitution made the Congress and the
president co-equal branches of
government this bill has already proven
the wisdom of that choice and that's of
course because the bill will prevent
Donald Trump from unilaterally easing
sanctions that are in place against
Russia this is these are just very
strange times that we're living in here
we have a president choosing not to be
obstructionist by signing into law
something that he believes violates the
Constitution the defenders of Trump
along these lines though along hey he's
doing the right thing by not obstructing
their completely irredeemable right they
will never say they disapprove of the
job Trump is doing well it's also just
hard to find where Trump Center is I
mean what ideologically motivates him
yeah it's interesting too because Trump
the Trump administration wanted to lift
Russian sanctions in the first few days
but immediately they started if there
was any way out of this they would have
taken that option but they just couldn't
they were backed into a corner Trump's
next performance review with Putin is
going to be really I mean I'm sorry I'm
talking about completely equal meeting
of two international leaders I don't
know why I would call it a performance
review this is fascinating what is going
on and it's also clear Russia doesn't
like this they've been very clear that
they don't like this and that they're
there well maybe consequences to signing
the sanctions bill maybe consequences
are a P tape being released I don't know
if that P tape exists that that has to
be someone there's hackers all over the
world doing incredible things that only
like Trump doesn't understand but Baron
Trump he's amazing with computers maybe
he understands what these hackers are
doing they've got to be close to getting
access to that p tape if it exists right
I think so cuz I maybe will someday find
out about that the video you just
watched was made possible by support
from you please go to patreon.com slash
david pakman show you can make a pledge
of as little as $1 per month and every
dollar helps to support the work that
we're doing particularly in light of the
YouTube ad boycott which has been really
bad